la zone artisanale foucherolles de saint
denis est en perpétuelle transformation
une trentaine d'entreprises de
différents secteurs d'activité ils sont
implantés
mais alors il y aurait il un rapport
entre foucherolles et l'économie locale
ce que vous savez qu'ils étaient
foucherolles du taux du tout je sais pas
bonne question
si on m'en a travaillé dans l'industrie
dans le bâtiment ou un truc comme ça
un homme politique peut-être enfin
sûrement pourquoi y était c'est lui qui
a créé la zac avec son entreprise et de
l'autre côté la basse un propriétaire il
y avait comme un conte je ne sais quoi
pour commune prima mais foucherolles ça
je sais pas non je ne crois pas j'ai pas
reconnue du tout
foucherans l'a été le premier directeur
de la compagnie des indes à s'intéresser
véritablement à bourbon à l'aube du
xviiie siècle alors que tous ne voient
dans l'île qu'une escale fougerolles
souhaite y développer une colonie de
peuplement ou une base maritime
il demande alors toute la documentation
possible sur bourbon le premier rapport
est rejetée il propose d'aménager
l'embouchure de la rivière d'abord pour
un montant de 50 mille écus curieux
foucherolles continue d'éplucher les
recensements fournis par antoine boucher
et envoie un émissaire étudier les
aptitudes agricole de l'île en 1710 sur
cette base il rédige un volumineux
mémoire sur l'île bourbon dans lequel il
est question pour la première fois du
développement de l'île en tant que tel
des idées à contre-courant c'est l'île
maurice qui a la préférence
quatre ans plus tard toutefois c'est en
proposant d'y développer la culture du
café que foucherolles lance
véritablement l'essor économique de
bourbon dès lors s'en est fini de l'air
sauvage d'un millier d'habitants
en dix ans bourbon devient l'un des
principaux fournisseurs de café de
l'europe